our series changing the game profiles
extraordinary women who are making a
difference now and for future
generations this morning we're
introducing you to a virginia teenager
bringing new attention to women who are
often left out of the history books the
high schooler developed her own
curriculum for elementary and middle
school students to recognize the
accomplishments of women with an
emphasis on women of color nicole
killian shows us how she did it
priscilla padmanaban is leading a modern
day crusade to rewrite the history books
some of these are really easy some of
them are not in one of the country's
largest school districts the 17 year old
is creating an entire course of study
for elementary and middle school
students in fairfax county virginia what
motivated you to develop this curriculum
honestly i think it was just my own
experience with the lack of education
around women's history i felt like
especially women of color were often
just their stories would go untold i am
a first generation indian and my mom is
an indian immigrant and so i think
growing up hearing her stories has
always been something that i have taken
and wanted to learn more about and
always been inspired by she founded a
group called where women for education
advocacy and rights the organization
launched a petition last year to
integrate more women's history in their
local schools
[Music]
it comes amid a heated debate over
public education curriculums in virginia
earlier this year republican governor
glenn younkin signed an executive order
banning public educational programs that
he claims are inherently divisive like
critical race theory what do you say to
any parents out there or students who
feel
why am i learning this why should i have
to learn this
i think that you know if we disregard
what really happened in our history then
we're not getting the full picture and
we're not going to be informed citizens
going forward when you first read her
proposal what did you think
i thought i need to meet this person
priscida's efforts caught the attention
of dr debra march an education
specialist who connected her with
fairfax county teachers if you just look
at curriculum standards and notice who
gets to be an individual with a name and
a biography and who is identified as a
group women during the civil war right
and so presidio really helped us lift up
the individual stories and contributions
of women from the revolutionary war we
all know paul revere was the man who
said that the british are coming but
civil ludington was a 16 year old girl
who rode horseback overnight to deliver
the same exact message to the civil war
susie king taylor who was a nurse during
the civil war and civil rights claudette
colvin started the montgomery bus
boycotts she actually started it nine
months before rosa parks we're going to
use some resources that ware has created
each lesson is crafted as a presentation
to spark discussions about game changing
female figures she was born to a free
black family in the north julie carrill
teaches sixth grade american history
even you were saying this is a lesson
for you as well we featured five
different women in the lesson today and
i had never heard of any of them a
learning experience for teacher and
students it means that maybe i can do
something important
i think that they should be taught
all year round if we learned more about
this who knows how many more women we
would acknowledge and know what is your
ultimate goal
my ultimate goal is that
every student across virginia and across
the country just learns equally about
women i don't ever want a student to ask
the question why does women's history
matter i want people to just know that i
want women's history to be history and i
want that to be a concept that every
student learns and understands for cbs
mornings nicole killian washington
i think this is so powerful you know for
the simple fact that
our education growing up depends on the
schools we're in and then once we get to
college it's tailored towards the
degrees that we're pursuing so there's
gaps that we all have and i think this
young lady said you know what we can
change that we can open up our
curriculum and really highlight some of
these women that we are not learning
about yeah and i think the children of
today they have google right there they
have youtube they can look up
documentaries or they it seems like they
are seeking out that information yeah um
to see a young
woman like uh priscida do that yeah it's
encouraging yeah i love it she's she
studied about women that have made an
impact and then she became one yeah yeah
look at that folks all right